[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
May 30th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
enough with bills and the pressures on
your personal finances can be stressful
for a lot of people but young adults are
applying a risky solution avoiding
facing their finances altogether we'll
hear from a 22 year old Florida resident
about his experience in a moment but
first Oyen adidoyan from The Wall Street
Journal personal finance department
joins us with more on what drives young
people to avoid keeping their finances
in order so oyan how has Financial
stress risen for young adults in
particular in recent years and what's
caused it it's really just the economic
Whiplash of the pandemic in the early
days of the pandemic we were all indoors
so there wasn't as much temptation to
spend outside of the home and there was
a lot of money coming into households
from the government to help out those
who were unemployed due to the pandemic
and so going from a period of you know
having so much money and nowhere to
really spend it for lack of a better
words to then you know going out into
the world into this High inflation
economy it was really difficult for a
lot of young people who are getting
their first jobs to adjust to our
culture is really big on over
consumption so we're constantly spending
on things just to self-soothe and maybe
that includes going online and you know
checking and seeing that your friends
are going out and doing something or
going out and buying something new or
having this lavish vacation and do you
have fear of missing out so you spend
money that you maybe don't have what
kind of an effect is it having on their
personal finances so the effect this has
had is really just ignoring your bank
and credit card accounts as those
expenses are going up and as money is
coming out of your bank account people
kind of have this urge to just not even
look for fear of what they're going to
find and so young adults with lower wage
jobs might avoid budgeting and even
checking bills because it makes them
feel helpless if they don't have the
finances to support their expenses you
know budgeting might just make you feel
even worse and Millennials in their 30s
had the steepest increase in debt of any
group since the pandemic and you know
that's because Millennials are often
referred to as the sandwich generation
they both had to support young kids
living at home while also supporting
maybe aging relatives and family members
as well and so avoidance can really
complicate these later Milestones that
young adults are going through including
buying a home or even saving for
retirement now you spoke to not only
financial experts about this but also
psychologists about what causes people
to just turn their back on addressing
stress like this what do they tell you
they told me that avoidance is a common
coping mechanism for all forms of
anxiety so someone with social anxiety
is going to avoid parties someone with a
fear of heights might never get on a
plane the apa's stress in America 2022
survey found that 83 percent of adults
reported inflation as a source of stress
so people are really anxious about their
finances right now 22 year old Florida
resident James gay faced anxiety after
he overspent during the pandemic and he
learned some hard lessons about managing
his personal finances so the pandemic
kinda sent me on a little bit of a
spiral if I'm being quite honest so I
really just did not like being shut in I
um turned to online shopping for my
outlet and doordashings I absolutely
adore Crocs so I turn to buying a lot of
those Oh you mean Crocs the shoes right
Crocs the shoes I absolutely love those
in total I would say before the pandemic
I maybe had One Singular pair of Crocs
now I have about 15 or 16 pair I
actually
just bought a pair last week they
released a pair of Croc boots and I love
them so much so it was a lot of just
buying just things to have and then
there's always eating every day you're
not going to want to cook especially me
so I started doordashing and ubereats
and just eating out quite a bit and then
not only are you paying for the food but
you're paying for the delivery of the
food I had a lot of bad spending habits
during the pandemic and it's just kind
of you know through all of the
Necessities to the side they were more
like a oh here's this bill that I have
to pay oh wow I forgot about that one it
was very taxing when did you realize
this was something you had to fix in the
back of my head I was always like I
really shouldn't be doing this but there
was no real James stop it right now up
until my dad actually made me get a
credit card to help keep building my
credit and I had a limit on it and he
told me to not go over a certain
percentage and I just kept swiping
swiping swiping and not only did I go
over that percentage he told me not to
go over but I almost maxed it out and
next thing I know I'm getting a call and
I'm getting chewed out about it and so
that was kind of my hard signal that
James you're doing a lot because you
knew better you were getting calls from
who my dad so we have connected accounts
through the credit union
and um his name is also on the credit
card so Not only was it affecting my
credit but it was affecting his so how'd
you go about fixing this first what I
did was I definitely just worked and
paid off that credit card bill so I just
kind of took a day and I sat down and
budgeted everything out from uh
unnecessary spending to necessary
spending bills and then actually how
much I was making each month in each
week so how are your Finance is doing
now much better I actually opened
another account for bills and things so
as soon as I get paid every week I
transfer a certain amount of money to
that account so it can't be touched
until you know it's time for bills now
James if we went into another economic
condition that challenged the way that
you handle your finances what lessons
will you keep in mind so I'd say
definitely be wise and aware of your
budgeting decisions and don't do any
unnecessary spending
is back with us now oh yeah we often
talk about the importance of budgeting
and setting goals as a way to better
handle your personal finances but for
people who've gotten behind on payments
or who want to avoid getting bogged down
in debt in the first place is there more
to it than that yeah it definitely is
psychological and you have to catch
yourself when you're going on those
spending sprees so what James went
through is really telling because he
went on this spending spree of buying
Crocs you know and his dad called him he
really had a moment where he had to face
reality and and start budgeting for
other people this can look like you know
setting financial goals for themselves
by ways of putting a limit on how much
money they spend every month so Alexis
another young adult that I spoke with
she basically puts herself on a specific
spending limit for non-discretionary
spending which includes dining out
buying clothes and doing fun vacations
and things with friends and so every
month she limits how much money she
spends on those things another thing
that financial advisors recommend is
making financial goals Fun by setting
them with friends so let's say you know
you and your friend want to go on a
vacation you can make a deal to put out
fifty dollars from each paycheck every
month into a separate account to save
for that vacation that way you have
something that psychologists call a
accountability partner and it makes
those financial goals a lot less
daunting that's Wall Street Journal
personal finance reporter Oyen adodoyan
and that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you